in the previous video we were asked to
plot the following complex numbers on
the Argand plane if you haven't tried it
I suggest you pause the video and try it
out okay the first complex number is 1
plus 2i how do we write it as an ordered
pair it can be written as 1 comma 2 real
part and the imaginary part let's draw
the Argand plane the horizontal axis is
the real axis and the vertical axis is
the imaginary axis to plot this point we
move one unit right on the real axis and
2 units up on the imaginary axis this
will be the point let's call it point a
it is pretty easy right what about the
next one negative 2 plus I the real part
is negative 2 and the imaginary part is
1 times I hence the ordered pair can be
written as negative 2 comma 1 2 units to
the left on the real axis and one unit
up on the imaginary axis that's the
second point point B boy you're able to
plot the third one it's just negative 4i
which can also be written as 0 minus 4i
the real part does not exist or we can
say that it's 0 and the imaginary part
is negative 4i the ordered pair can be
written as 0 comma negative 4 it can be
plotted here on the y axis remember
anything of the form 0 plus bi will be
on the imaginary axis and what about the
last one negative 2i plus 1 the ordered
pair can be written as negative 2 comma
1 right this is a very common mistake
that students make when they are in a
hurry a complex number is always written
in the form a plus bi and not VI plus a
so this is actually 1 minus 2i which
makes the ordered pair 1 comma negative
and it can be plotted here in the fourth
quadrant I am sure your
to build with plotting complex numbers
now but wait did you observe something 1
minus 2i is the complex conjugate of 1
plus 2i and this point on the organ play
is the mirror image of this one along
the real axis that's an important point
the complex conjugate of a complex
number will always be its mirror image
across the real axis
[Music]